hello everyone and welcome back to this
series where I'm playing rapid chess
unleashes 10 minutes per player I'm
commenting on my games uh discussing my
thought process and hopefully I'm
helping some some of you learn what to
what to look for in certain positions uh
for those of you who are uh Beyond My
Level I also welcome you to add some uh
comments about how I should improve what
the you know if you if you if you
realize that I'm significantly weaker in
some aspects of the game than other uh
maybe you should also uh you
help me out with that but mostly I'm
doing this to help um lower rated
players who are on their journey to
mastering the game so let's check it out
last game we had the white pieces this
one no or do we have black yeah I don't
remember anymore uh but uh we we have
white here and we play against um mcga
Sim uh who we don't know where where
he's from or where she's from so okay we
have the Sicilian Defense and we're
going to go for Knight to F3 yeah we had
the white pieces in the previous game
where I played the uh it attack uh but
here I mentioned that this is the only
Sicilian where I play B4 right away so
we'll see uh if uh if uh my theory
knowledge about this B4 Sicilian
challenge is up to the task or do I have
to improve on it so obviously our
opponent here uh doesn't meet this quite
often which means that he will either
ignore it where we can advance the pawn
to B5 and grab more space here or he
will capture it you know uh just to see
why I would play such a move so both uh
both both are fine for me actually don't
have anything prepared if my opponent
doesn't capture this uh so yeah but it
you know it makes sense to capture since
it's the strongest move so we're going
to play D4 now he should stop this
either by playing D5 or E6 E6 is okay so
he goes for G6 right away all right
we're going
to uh how do we how do we approach this
G6 right away yeah makes sense why
not why
not just go Bishop C4 pretend like we're
playing a normal game and we just gave a
pawn for for
development yeah why
not oh he goes for Knight to F6 first
okay now we're going to kick it away now
we're going to kick it away and we we're
already looking okay he might go D5 here
might also not be a terrible idea yeah
because if he doesn't go D5 here then we
might have even some Bishop captures an
F7 action
here so I have no idea what to make of
this he's uh going for for a pretty
unique move
order yeah so I'm not sure about this
whole Bishop to C4 business but uh he he
you know he he disregarded the the fight
for the center of the board so you know
why
not we'll see what it does if D5 usually
yeah he will play D5 and now since I
don't know uh specifically how to tackle
this I might even just uh move the
bishop yeah he he gets the E4 Square
maybe for his Knight do I care about
that not
particularly I could I mean I could just
capture and then if he captures even
Advance the pawn to D5 might not be a
terrible terrible
plan okay let's see what happens I don't
think this is in this particular setup
uh like you have some lines where where
you should play uh Pawn to pawn to B uh
Bishop to B5 first uh but I think here
we should just grab more space
yeah we'll see we'll see what what he
thinks about
it and uh yeah we might just even after
the Knight moves just Castle yeah we
don't care about captures we don't care
about the pawn push Pawn push actually
might be nice but no I I don't believe
such a thing is
possible yeah I'm just going to let him
decide so if he captures if I Castle he
captures I'm going to play Rook e one
Che he he has to block with Bishop D7
there there's no good move here I'm
pretty sure that's not good for him so
yeah uh I will let him explain what uh
what his plan is regarding
development he going to go Bishop G4
okay perfectly
fine
how to make the most out of the
position
uh yeah this is a a very rich
position so what if I play Rook e one
what what what what's his plan he will
play E6 then how is
he
yeah I don't think
so yeah he will have to play
something or he moves the queen and he
actually castles Queen side yeah I I
don't know about that
either we might have some C3 ideas here
with Queen A4 check since the Knight
here is fairly poorly placed for the
moment as long as the D5 Pawn is alive
so he might include Bishop captures on
F3 to avoid with that but other than
that I think we're just uh dominating
the center of the
board like we we might even Force his
hand with Bishop to G5 yeah okay so he
now goes after the F6
Pawn
um we can we can actually ignore E6 E6
is not
really that big of a
deal
yeah capturing
now
H yeah
okay you do have you do have this that's
true
[Music]
uh I'm also considering Rook captures on
E6 but not right now as the bishop here
controls it
so yeah this doesn't look like something
that he should be able to play and yet
he plays it very
interesting
okay let's just keep the tension there's
no there's no need to rush anything here
let's just keep the
tension he can't really capture on D5 as
long as the The Rook controls the E file
yeah and now my idea is that if if he
develops the bishop then I can even
control him with Bishop to H6
Maybe yeah we'll see what it does if my
knight was developed I wouldn't have uh
any hesitation here as I would be able
to capture here without worrying about
this and then even go further but uh
yeah I kind of don't want
to allow the queen trade here uh and
also having to move the
Rook so we'll see what he does next how
does he develop the bishop
that's okay so he will capture yeah
makes sense to avoid any action on the
queen side capture here and now I don't
think that his position is even playable
what he just blundered the queen okay
yeah okay see he uh yeah not the
best yeah okay uh but uh yeah okay so he
goes for this we can even sacrifice The
Rook uh as there's really no move he can
make
okay uh so that was uh fairly clean do
we have a fancy way of finishing the
game no we can just capture and mate
here
okay uh but yeah I'm I'm very much
interested in what what just happened
there since uh I always recommend this
B4 line against the
Sicilian uh let's just check
why what what went so poorly for him so
okay I play E4 C5 and the B4 so best is
to capture uh sometimes with the pawn
sometimes with the Knight some sometimes
players will capture with the with the
Knight sometimes with the pawn but your
idea is the same like here uh b c
captures on B4 was played and I grabbed
the full Center but if Knight captures
then you challenge the Knight and then
you go sort of a Evans Gambit structure
captures captures uh and okay E6 but
most players will just play D5 here you
will play Knight to C3 and then you will
get something like this with Bishop to
D2 and there are some funny lines here
like E6 you can go Rook B1 and after
Bishop to B4 you can even capture here
sort of a forced line that allows um
white a lot of action Queen E4 check
Bishop E3 and it's not easy to play this
as there there are so many threats like
Knight to C7 with check the bishop
coming into the game um so yeah it's uh
pretty tricky but my opponent went for B
Cs and C4 I played D4 he played G6 which
uh yeah should be met with the uh with
A3 and A3 is pretty standard
continuation to B4 I think it's like
even called the the
mearini um variation of the Sicilian I
played Bishop C4 he played Knight F6
yeah now E5 D5 I played captus he played
captus I played D5 yeah and already
slight Advantage for white but nothing
Alo F5
here F5 here that's very interesting no
okay Knight F5 is is strongest but why
why why was a bishop to F5 a
consideration what is this bad captures
captures and then que side castles okay
and he does have some very nasty
pressure here or if I move my king yeah
he captures here and then he has
compensation for the piece so it's very
tricky you can't just you know capture a
piece so yeah after castles if if a
bishop to F5 move is played you just
castle and then continue so okay Knight
A5 I castled the bishop to G4 and I
played yeah so C3 the move we discussed
with the threat of Queen A4 check uh
does seem to be the way to go but also
captures is very nice here so just
captures captures ah simply because of
captures captures and queen D4 with a
double attack yeah
okay okay jokes on me it was a free
Bishop yeah okay but it's such a
complicated line I mean both you and
your opponent will miss stuff here I
played The Rook D1 again Capt was the
way to go I play Rook E1 E6 I played
Bishop G5 and now Bishop G5 not that
impressive yeah he had H6 here H3 okay
we just trade he played captures I
played captures yeah now his position is
just lost here yeah it's okay uh so not
uh not much of a game uh by you know we
we both missed stuff here but uh you
know I'm always happy to advertise uh
Pawn to B4 Sicilian uh if you guys enjoy
it maybe try it it's incredibly
complicated to play uh because whatever
your opponent plays there's like a you
know 10 hidden traps behind the move but
you know if you like to calculate if you
like to play tricky moves uh maybe this
is just the weapon you've been looking
for so yeah here we took down a 2300
opponent and we didn't really work all
that hard for our meal even though it
could have easily gone the other way uh
around but that's just one day you know
you give your opponent a lesson the next
game the next day he gives you one uh so
yeah that's the game I hope you guys
enjoyed a bit of a shorter one today but
you know we can't have every day
fighting for our lives sometimes it's
going to be a shorter game what are you
going to do uh so as usual you can check
two of my previous videos thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and also you know playing
some rapid to improve everyone's uh mood
and knowledge see you
soon